bonjour xavier moreau merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france à leur
première question donald trump est il
réellement contourner de manière
unilatérale le régime de contrôle de la
technologie des missiles
oui oui tu te fais ça ne lui posera
aucun problème il est tout à fait maître
dans ce genre dans ce genre de décision
et de toute manière il sera soutenu par
l'ensemble de l'establishment américain
donc là dessus il en sortira comme il
est sorti des autres traités lui
d'ailleurs et georges bouchard le
premier qui a des mots qui a commencé à
démanteler tout système de sécurité qui
avait été mis en place pendant la guerre
froide et dans les années 90 ces gens
que je bush en 2001 lorsqu'il est sorti
du du traité sur les missiles
antimissiles
depuis son arrivée à la maison blanche à
donald trump à romagné plusieurs
réglementations en matière
d'exportations d'armes il a même retiré
les états unis de plusieurs traités
internationaux
pourquoi aujourd'hui remettre en
question ce pacte est ce que il s'agit
là seulement d'exporter plus de drones
unitaire alors comme je voulais dit ça
ça s'inscrit dans une stratégie qui a
démarré depuis les années 2000 c'est à
dire de sortir de dérèglement de
réglementation internationale des grands
accords internationaux
l'amérique veut veut faire son cavalier
seul en organisant plus ou moins de
chaos
là où ça lui est possible on met son
hégémonie ça c'est une première chose je
dirais une vision globale et après il a
il faut être honnête
les etats unis sont en pointe dans le
domaine des drones ces les premiers à
avoir investi dans cette technologie
et il est vrai que cette technologie est
à la portée d'autres pays c'est
davantage du drone par rapport aux
avions de chasse si vous les embrouiller
trois pays qui sa fabrique à rêves ou de
chasse modernes c'est un récit des états
unis la france un drone est une
technologie beaucoup plus accessible
puisque des pays comme la turquie
on l'a vu dans notamment dans en syrie
des pays comme israël sont très
performants et donc ce serait
effectivement de match pour le complexe
militaro-industriel américain ne pas
être capable de d'exporter ses armements
dans lesquelles il
sans doute le le premier producteur
vendre plus de drones pourraient aider
les pays alliés des etats unis à lutter
contre le terrorisme
établir des contrôles aux frontières et
de manière générale à stopper des
menaces avant qu'elles n'atteignent le
sol américain c'est ce qu'a déclaré la
directrice du pentagone qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette explication
écoutez je crois qu on nous a fait le
coup de la guerre contre le terrorisme
de george bush le drone est une arme
pourquoi est-ce que ça avait été on en
avait des limites et d'exportation en
1987 parce que en fait c'est
l'équivalent d'un missile c'est à dire
que vous pouvez mettre dessus une bombe
nucléaire si vous être capable de
produire une bombe chimique ou ce que
vous voulez donc de parler de la luttre
de la lutte contre le terrorisme c'est
purement on va dire delà de la
dialectique en fêtard droit ne peut
permettre de faire tout et n'importe
quoi vous prenez par exemple les drones
turcs ont été utilisés en syrie à
l'origine c'est des drones ces des
drones d'observation et puis des turcs
se sont aperçus que pour ajoutant
quelques bons dessus et bien on pourra
en faire des systèmes d' attaque au sol
tous que voilà oui ça sera peut-être
utilisés pour la surveillance utilisées
dans la guerre contre le terrorisme
j'imagine que si jamais les américains
on board a dans la vie saoudite ils vont
les utiliser contre les quilles au
maillet mène donc c'est encore une fois
assez de la dialectique faut comprendre
le pentagone et surtout la vision
américaine d'essayer de donner toujours
une explication morale d'opérations
globalement quelle conséquence à cette
décision peut-elle engendrer au niveau
géopolitique
écoutez on y voir une chose ça ne prend
pas ça ne provoquera pas de grands de
grands changements géopolitiques parce
que les drones
concerne les puissances d'hier les
petites puissances militaires dès que
vous avez en face d'eux des grandes
puissances comme la russie les grandes
puissances les grandes heures
européennes
les drones sont extrêmement vulnérables
donc c'est plutôt ça va plutôt concerné
je dirais des conflits de moyenne
intensité et très localisée pas comme
par exemple je suis tu es celui de
l'arabie saoudite contre les outils
voilà ça va ça va donner
ça va donner un une force aérienne
supplémentaires à certains pays qui
n'ont pas forcément toujours les moyens
soit d'acheter des avions ce soin de
bien de les entretenir de faire voler
leurs pilotes etc
on a vu notamment l'ukraine qui a
commencé à déployer des drones justement
parce que ces pilotes ne colle plus ne
savent plus beau laid et finalement ça
ça peut effectivement être un facteur
déstabilisant puisque ça ça va être là
l'armée de l'air du pauvre merci
beaucoup
xavier moreau d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
analyste et directeur de ce tract paul
centre d'analystes politiques aux
stratégies